new york schauplatz eines entführungs
komplotts iranische geheimdienst jagen
ihren staatsfeind nummer eins masih ali
j prominente iranische regime kritikerin
sollte nach teheran verschleppt werden
seither muss die 45-jährige jeden ihrer
schritte mit den fbi abstimmen auch wir
werden eingehend überprüft dann dürfen
wir sie in new york treffen
als das fbi sagte der iran will dich
kidnappen nahm ich das nicht ernst doch
als ich die fotos unseres hauses saadi
ein detektiv gemacht hatte war ich
schockiert sie wollten mich mit einem
schnellboot nach venezuela entführen
einem verbündeten iran
das entführungs komplott fliegt auf
seitdem steht masia linie schott unter
polizeischutz sie nimmt uns mit in ihr
haus und zeigt uns videos den mord und
anschlagsdrohungen gegen sie gibt es
schon länger
frau masia linie j wir werden bald ihr
gesicht mit säure verletzten damit sie
iranische frauen nicht länger in ehren
sie haben angst vor meinen
kommunikationskanälen daher wollen sie
mich mundtot machen sie sehen dass ich
bei instagram und twitter oder facebook
7 millionen follower diese plattform
nutzen die menschen in iran die keine
freien medien haben und das regime will
nicht dass die welt ihre stimme hört
von den usa aus setzt masia teenager die
sozialen medien gezielt gegen die
herrscher in teheran ein mit ihrer 2014
gestarteten internetkampagne wednesday
ermutigt sie frauen ihre kopftücher
abzulegen und sich dabei zu filmen
darauf stehen zehn jahre haft auch die
23-jährige szabo hier rechts sitzt dafür
im gefängnis
diese frauen sind meine helden weil sie
gegen das sowohl der religiösen diktatur
protestieren den kopftuchzwang er ist
das symbol der taliban dass sie es und
des iranischen regimes erst wie die
berliner mauer wenn du dir unter reist
bleibt nichts mehr vom regime übrig
daher will das regime in teheran sie mit
allen mitteln zum schweigen bringen
schon als junge parlaments reporterin
kritisiert sie zu hohe einkünfte eines
abgeordneten sind ex präsident khatami
trotz verbot etwas vor
würden sie zu hören wenn ich ein lied
singen das hat noch niemand getan ich
habe eine schöne stimme
[Musik]
eine provokation mit folgen sie darf
nicht mehr aus dem parlament berichten
und geht 2009 ins exil um eine haft zu
vermeiden was mit regimekritikern im
ausland passieren kann musste ihr
kollege rosam erfahren der iranische
geheimdienst entführte ihn führte ihn im
staatsfernsehen vor später wird er
hingerichtet
wie wichtig ist die arbeit von marcia
lins für regimekritiker in iran ganz
entscheidend meint narges mohammadi
bekannte menschenrechtsaktivistin aus
teheran
folter hinrichtungen und lange
haftstrafen sind alltag in iranischen
gefängnissen
aber immer wenn der druck der aktivisten
von außen und im innern hoch ist wenn
die repressionen geringer auch ich habe
das im gefängnis erlebt
was sich nimmt uns mit auf america dem
staatlichen auslandssender die usa
letzte vorbereitungen mit ihrer eigenen
sendung tablet erreicht sie ein
millionenpublikum im exil und in iran
ihre kollegen schätzen besonders ihren
draht zu den einfachen leuten den iran
[Musik]
sie ist eine frau die aus einfachen
verhältnissen stammt aus einem kleinen
dorf im norden irans sie kommt aus der
mitte der gesellschaft kennt die nöte
der einfachen leute daher identifizieren
sich viele frauen mit ihr auch die
familien vieler opfer vertrauen
und das nutzt massig wie nach den
schweren unruhen 2009/10 gegen erhöhte
benzinpreise im iran damals wurden über
1500 menschen getötet auch der junge
puderbach theorie massiv steht in
ständigem kontakt mit seiner mutter
bittet die opfer mütter um videos und
sie liefern klagen das regime an
iran hat einen seiner ehrenhaften männer
verloren
nur durch maxi ali j gelang diese videos
an die öffentlichkeit sie hat ein
riesiges netzwerk wir begleiten sie zu
einem treffen mit der iranischen
community in washington viele hier
fühlen sich durch matisse kampf bestärkt
wenn ich als 16-jähriges mädchen in iran
verstehe dass es eine andere welt gibt
in der man frei sein kopftuch wählen
kann dann lerne ich auch dass ich in
meinem gesamten leben frei entscheiden
kann was
ihn nimmt auch die politik in die
pflicht hat ihrem fall und die
menschenrechtssituation im weißen haus
angesprochen vier personen in iran
wurden bisher sanktioniert eine in den
usa angeklagt
wir verurteilen irans hinterhältigen
versuch eine us bürgerin auf
amerikanischen gebiet zu kidnappen
kategorisch
es geht hier nicht nur um ein die usa
waren doch 1979 die ersten opfer einer
geiselnahme in ihrer botschaft in
teheran wenn die usa beim atom die die
menschenrechte nicht thematisieren
ebensee teheran einen freiplatz
und teheran lässt nicht locker auf dem
rückweg nach new york masih erzählt uns
dass laut fbi die mullahs sie jetzt
nicht mehr entführen sondern gezielt
töten wollen
wir dachten alles sei vorbei doch dann
rief das fbi um mitternacht an und wir
mussten in ein hotel später in ein
anderes haus ziehen ich dachte immer so
etwas betrifft nur jemanden wie salman
rushdie nicht mich
sie als kampf für die freiheit den iran
wird immer gefährlicher und das längst
nicht mehr nur in ihrer alten heimat
[Musik]